your friends with Woodly your friends
would ask her and you know everybody
would say hey both of them took a dive
with the fight
yeah the Jake Paul fight what are your
thoughts on that I I don't know I
honestly haven't talked to either of
them about it I don't think it's
probably it's probably a sore subject
for both of them I don't think it was a
a dive I could be wrong no I don't know
why watching Jake because now you know
people were criticizing them first fight
second fight third fight if you're kind
of like saying this guy kind of knows
what he's doing in his training and he's
kind of do you think he's got a
trajectory or do you think Silva's gonna
expose him and it's going to be like no
this is it it's done with I think he has
a trajectory I think he's very young in
the sport I think it it's still you can
be you can be
you can be somewhat critical of the fact
that yes he has not fought any
high-level boxers whatsoever and also
sing his Praises that he does look
pretty decent for a guy who is going out
there and fighting he's he can move he
he can move he's got fast hands